i thought i thought open open exchange
of ideas was welcome on youtube
no one this is why no one believes you
this is why no one believes you
and i hope that there is some
legislation that forces you to answer
for this idea of being
uh a public platform or a publisher
a circumstance and you're a teacher
copyright
chance even down on youtube copyright
vaccinated uh
is there a way to get it back up you're
still in blazes so and by the way
some teachers have already died all
right listen just to people who are
watching we got cop with a cnn copyright
do we know can we check
warner brothers how have we been taken
down from warner brothers warner
brothers own cnn oh time warner
is it time warner is it time warner time
warner has taken us down right now let's
uh
let's uh hold on one second uh we are
going to
uh well actually we're going to keep
covering this manny get out of here
right now smooth manny and figure out
how we're going to be getting back on
youtube
use the promo code crowder trump uh
crowder biden stream
sorry uh and that's the hashtag you get
twenty dollars off if you join mug club
we need to find out how to get this back
up they already have them they already
have people who are watching here on the
blaze muggle you might want to get it up
people know this is abs and by the way
we showed less of this
than ever before yeah we showed less of
this than ever before we might need to
get a half asian bill richmond on the
phone as well yeah
because this is absolutely unreal that
they did this so
quickly and so early on so what time
community 60
it's a youtube community guidelines due
to community guidelines strikes or
copyright issues you can
you can't live stream at this time oh so
it's a hard strike yeah so we're it's a
hard strike for clearly transformative
content where we are streaming this
right now
now here's the thing i bet you this is
what happened okay and i can't verify
this
but we didn't get any issue with the
trump lives now keep in mind abc disney
that was the company that went after us
before with the oscars and then they
stopped
they were not actively going after uh
streaming the trump livestream because
they assumed that it would all be
negative of course we
are still on facebook we are still on
facebook we're on facebook
but i well i'm telling people on
facebook or the blaze right now so
they're already there i can't tell
people to go
tell other people tell other people you
know what you you are right now you're
like the guy who forgets that the power
is out at his house
yeah turn the light on turn the camera
damn i was making dinner i guess i'll
just go microwave some soup the power's
out i can't tell i'm gonna go to
facebook
there is no problem and we showed far
more of the stream by the way with the
donald trump stream because they assumed
it would be negative
same thing right here like we talked
about with the dnc remember that when
all of a sudden
reg you remember this right you remember
that with the dnc stream joe biden's
speech
they changed the likes to dislikes ratio
now right of course it can happen when
there's a lag and likes can go
up later on but i have never seen
anywhere
else likes switch over from
mostly dislikes to then mostly likes and
fewer dislikes
so i want to be clear right here i'm not
saying that every time a video gets a
bunch of dislikes that it's a conspiracy
or that any time
that youtube all of a sudden uh includes
some likes on a biden speech that
there's a conspiracy but when you have
dislikes actually go down in number
while the likes go up in number which we
saw with the biden dnc
stream that is something that i have not
seen anywhere else
and we've always given youtube the
benefit of the data as it deals with
lags right now let's also keep in mind
that big tech again
youtube twitter facebook alphabet owns
google and they work
with time warner they work with abcd
these are some of the major sponsors who
spend money on youtube
we know this because we had to struggle
with both abc disney before and vox
universal
these are the people who are in cahoots
and have said that you should not accept
the election results on the night of the
election that they will fact
check it can anyone find for me as jack
dorsey has anyone at youtube or facebook
said that they will fact
check if biden declares victory on
election night can anyone find that
for me this is yet another example of i
don't want to say censorship
i want to say selective enforcement of
the rules
if youtube wants to say that you cannot
do a watch along with any kind of a town
hall
it needs to be applied equally we did it
with president trump
we did it with the dnc we're now doing
it here with the biden stream the only
thing
the only thing different is that it's
spied instead of trump and
something that sets some context here if
you look at the rnc
versus the dnc the feedback online
particularly on youtube was
overwhelmingly negative
for biden in the dnc and overwhelmingly
positive for trump
you don't think that someone at time
warner who again are some of the biggest
advertisers one of the biggest
partnerships with youtube that you could
possibly imagine
you don't think they said hey there's
something we've got to do here because
we are not pulling in the same numbers
online we're pulling in numbers with the
geriatrics who are being sold
reverse mortgages from magnum pi on
traditional television but online trump
is kicking our asses what can we do you
know what we'll make sure that we
enforce the copyright strikes and
community guidelines strikes no less
on the the biden stream going forward
again it just seems to be
all the time there are likes and
dislikes that switch with the biden dnc
and it goes in biden's favor selectively
it's enforced when it's not going well
for joe biden very clearly
uh all of a sudden the streams that are
critical of joe biden get taken off
it would be one thing if these little
mistakes went in both directions
but statistically they don't you can see
our previous videos where we've talked
about this for a very long time
statistically
it overwhelmingly favors the left
algorithmically just like tulsi gabbard
in those searches
just like when you searched stephen
crowder changed my mind abortion you
would find a six-year-old pbs video with
452 views
there is no balance in the errors that
occur
on youtube i don't care if they say hey
you can't do a live watch along
for trump or biden fine we'll do it here
exclusively at mug club that's fine we
can do it at the blaze that's
that's fine by me but you cannot allow
one and not
allow the other provided it's critical
that is the issue that we have is the
selective
application of the rules there is no
difference
in how we are covering this except for
the fact we've actually shown less of
the stream thus far
it was manually detected so that means
somebody manually strikes
our channel yeah yeah and and cnn's are
owned by turner i don't think it's
so i i don't know why why is wb i
understand
turner is at time warner
owns uh time cnn own cnn i believe
i got it mixed up can you find that for
us reg yeah sure i know it's charming
yeah
yeah warner media yeah so that's cnn
yeah and i mean the thing was
biden was not looking good tonight no he
has antenna
i was wrong he looked pretty bad so you
know it's
he was getting the numbers wrong and
saying we're gonna have 215
000 more deaths and uh mandate uh masks
and you're you're a quarter uh
quarterling
he's looking bad right now this is not
going well for him and they are softball
questions across the board
that's why they have people out there
shadow of a doubt right now with our
experience someone manually detected it
this wasn't automatic which should mean
by the way right now hopefully someone
makes a
call that someone can manually fix this
at youtube
immediately and by the way we know
because we have some of these folks
on speed dial youtube you are not
supposed to let this happen
step in and do the right thing you're
also on pacific time someone is in the
office right now
if only to have some kind of diversity
training we know that you do that on
thursdays
so make this right someone manually
fixed it someone manually
rigged this system right now you know
that it's a totally
invalid strike you know it we've talked
about this before every single time
we've had one of these strikes before
it has been resolved because it is
undoubtedly fair use
don't do the [ __ ] you say you have
to go through the system they didn't go
through the system someone abused a
system
manually and you want to talk about
david and goliath right
this is the idea too right this we were
talking about critical race theory
the idea of critical race theory is that
there's always an oppressor provided
that you're in some kind of a majority
that's the same reason that you have the
left the reason that they support
palestine over israel
just because one has actual weapons and
one has rocks
it doesn't matter that their charter
says throw rocks at someone for being a
jew and israel has a defense policy that
is hey defend yourself if someone throws
a rock at you for being a jew it's
hey you're the underdog therefore you
are morally correct the only place that
doesn't apply however
is when you have conservatives on new
media kicking the ass of legacy media
who have more money than god compared to
us
guess what ask me how much i own of
ladder with crowder how much do you own
take a guess take a wild guess one
hundred percent
and that's not biden math that's
accurate one hundred percent
ask me compared to uh even uh uh young
turks who have what 20 million
20 million in one round plus 15 million
from foreign investors al jazeera guitar
money
ask how much money i've ever received in
a as a lump sum to invest in louder with
crowder
zero dollars zero dollars we have a
licensing agreement with the blaze for
moments just like this and we are
incredibly appreciative of them where we
were already generating a profit for
them and so we split it so that we don't
have to do
all of the legwork with the paywall and
the app that's very difficult for us to
do
we have never had foreign investors or
outside mega investors come in
cnn obviously can't say that they're
owned by a multimedia conglomerate abc
news
disney vox universal nbc you can't even
say it about these new media entities on
the left
like the young turks and almost anyone
is in their network
let's see what happens by the way with
them right now let's see what happens as
they cover these events it is remarkable
i'm not bitching i just want equal
application
of the rules right now someone manually
flagged this you know it's bullsh
youtube you can manually fix it let's
hopefully get that going
now i do have to tell you that youtube
has just emailed and said we can start a
new stream if we like
oh that'd be great just start from zero
yeah oh well that's very nice i don't
think we don't want to start streaming
on youtube now do we
no we no give we don't give them well
listen hey
youtube i i will say this i appreciate
that they got on it quickly but uh you
couldn't do that
in 2018 youtube you couldn't do that
some
guy with a hotmail address got the
better of you
you want to convince us that you guys
are the end-all be-all of tech and we
should also trust you as it relates to
your
your unbiased algorithms and we don't
want to erode trust in american
institutions
but all of a sudden the search results
for tulsi gabbard and steven crowder
changed my mind don't show up we should
trust youtube
but you can't deal with a guy with an
ipad
and a hotmail address well thank you
that
all that's happened is our sponsorship
revenue and our actual stream which you
know has been more popular than these
main network streams for a long
time didn't get to air so you know what
i guess let's call it a wash
or you can lick my balls youtube
and start getting it right from here on
out you know what we were going to be
selling that shirt of my mug
pissing on the youtube logo but now
we're going to mark that down in price
just so we can
sell it like it's tickle me elmo in the
1990s you sons of
i am so tired of this [ __ ] from youtube
oh we fixed it now
first off you could have fixed it within
minutes okay even just your little
community guideline strikers who walk
out like
regarded ewoks okay shooting i don't
even know what that is that's a bad
thing and are there good guys in star
wars
my point is you could have fixed it
immediately when it happened
you didn't until it was done and you
could have fixed it two years ago when
the sky was
serial flagging content how do you not
have a system in place
to verify some kind of authentic
authority for people
to have content removed i thought i
thought opening
open exchange of ideas was welcome on
youtube no one this is why no one
believes you
this is why no one believes you and i
hope that there is some legislation
that forces you to answer for this idea
of being
uh a public platform or a publisher i
really do
so thank you for getting it right an
hour and a half later but you know what
we don't get that revenue back nope it's
gone
we don't get it back it's kind of like
if the nigerian scammer you've been
sending money since 2018
right you know yeah yeah which by the
way youtube also did because nigerian
what trust do we have yeah
let's just send it to him what can we do
it has nigeria in the name
well they know that they can't actually
stand up to a free exchange of ideas
they know that byron can't handle
being criticized they know that they
know that trump needs to have
trump needs to actually you know take a
few steps down if he's actually going to
be able to compete with biden but biden
again
biden they're giving him every single
advantage that they can and he's still
biting you know what it is after the
fact what kind of effect do you think
that has had on the
on the uh the interpretation of the
biden town hall
right how many people you're talking
about millions of people who watch these
right
people who stay we know this compared to
television where the average watch time
is
measured by seconds hours by how many
half hours people watch
youtube you know that that's why it
really stung for you to demonetize this
channel because we don't post clickbait
50 videos a day like the young turks we
post
one to this channel and then several
clips to crowder bits uh
it's an oopsies after the fact they want
to pull that same oopsies after the fact
with mail in voting it's the same thing
you don't get it back guys
you don't get it back it's a system
that's untested
where we have tested it it hasn't worked
it's been a monumental script
it's been a screw-up of bluto blue
tarsky proportions
and you want us to trust you going into
the election it's like youtube right now
saying
hey we can't tell you who our
accountability uh
uh uh partners are here we can't tell
you who determines what is advertiser
friendly
what is guideline friendly we can't tell
you what is considered borderline
content which is a third standard by the
way outside of community guidelines and
advertiser friendly something that a lot
of people don't know
we can't tell you that but you should
trust us and by the way
you should trust us even though someone
who goes around false flagging since
2018 with a hotmail account got the
better of us
you should trust us we don't know
exactly how mail-in voting is going to
work compared to absentee voting we have
some kind of verification process for
identification and confirmation of
address we do know that it didn't work
really well where we tried it we had
over 60 000 votes i believe something
like that in new jersey that had to be
measured after the election to about
hundreds of votes and other we do know
where we've done it hasn't worked that
well but you should trust us and
after the election after joe biden has
refused to concede because he said that
he would and hillary clinton encouraged
him to do anything
other than concede and twitter and
facebook and youtube have jumped on
board saying we will fact check anyone
claiming that donald trump wins on
election night because we believe in
this completely unvetted
unchecked process unauthenticated
unverified process
but you should trust us and then
afterwards they go oopsie
only we have the wrong guy in office
well guess what i don't trust you
i trust you youtube about as far as i
could throw chris cuomo and granted
that's pretty far
because he doesn't have the bone density
you know that's what happens like
steroids you look bigger than you
actually weigh because there isn't the
same kind of connective tissue
but i'll look for when i throw them
brittle bones
um i trust you about as far as i could
throw chris cuomo which is pretty far
but not far enough so i'm not willing to
listen i don't have the png to come down
this is what i got for you youtube
and this came from wardrobe so these
pants are a little bit tight
get it
you like it like anderson cooper's
purple tie
[Laughter]
actually it is purple because these have
been riding up on me so i'm sure it
would look like a purple beating heart
um
guess who i am i'm josh hartnett
i bet you didn't think you'd see that
face in a while this is what we call an
end card which is where i tell you that
you should subscribe if you like this
video or click one of these other videos
that you may like hit the notification
bell of course join mug club because
that's what allows us to continue doing
these videos
and just so you know youtube actually
has created a new policy
where they might start outright banning
channels that are no longer commercially
viable
which means that this is merely a
figment of your imagination